it'd be amazing if we could talk about
the observational aspect of this the
tools of observation so what telescopes
have you used do you use and what does
the data look like and I think I've read
a few interesting stories about the
actual process of day-to-day observation
a bunch of uh probably late nights
well yeah astronomers are doing it all
night long so oh yeah
can you explain the all night long
aspect of it
um well let me start by saying uh I
mostly these days use the Magellan
telescopes in Chile they are 6.5 meter
telescope which means the the mirror
diameter 6.5 meter that's not the
largest that is out there but it's among
the largest and
um I use a spectrograph because I'm a
spectroscopist I don't take pictures
um and that particular spectrograph at
that telescope is actually
um unusually efficient so it kind of
makes up for the fact that the mirror
isn't as large in let's say the eight
meter telescopes from the Europeans or
so so I'm very happy with that
efficiency meaning how many photons get
collected sort of per time unit because
we that that's always the the limiting
factor
um
uh prior to the pandemic we would travel
to Chile to do our observations
um those telescopes are the that's the
last Observatory where people were sort
of supposed to travel there and take
their own observations most other
observatories
basically have staff there by now who
take the observations for you
so there's the directly the scientists
are
uh specifying where to point the
telescope and sitting there and
collecting the data making sure the data
is collected well the cleaning of the
data the what offloading of the data all
that kind of stuff yeah so it's mostly
done for them yeah
um obviously that's super convenient but
it also takes takes away a central part
of what the work of an astronomer is
which is data collection
right we don't have an experiment in the
basement where we can go day and night
or whenever we please
um and ask a certain question of the
apparatus right let's turn this knob and
see what happens let's turn that knob
and see what happens no you know we we
only have one experiment uh which is the
universe and we what we see is what we
get
and I think it's it's so important to to
take an active role in that so I really
loved going to the observatory I've
taken many students there over the years
to to teach them and to
just show them what it means to to be in
astronomer because you you go to the
these remote mountain tops and it's such
a magical environment and you wait there
you know for the sun to go down and then
you get ready and you look outside and
it's it's such a Serene environment
um it's it's a little bit out of this
world you're sitting there so the sun
goes down it's evening late evening
and uh what does it look like what are
some of the most magical experiences of
that process well you know when you're
on top of a mountain uh you know
climbers I guess get to see that
probably
um otherwise um
it's it's very calm and the colors are
so beautiful and
I always become much calmer when I'm
there I'm just a because I'm just there
for one purpose only that's data
collection
I can say no to my emails I can say no
to everything else because I'm observing
so there's literally less less
distractions because you know you're
just there to do one thing and also the
emails somehow seem less significant
yeah yeah it's just you can afford to
focus on this one thing and you
it just kind of does something to you
it's it's a it's a little hard to
describe but
um you know if you then fast forward
maybe I can speak a little bit about
that and I have done a lot of
astrophotography there as well so and
and I observing faint dwarf Galaxy Stars
you know these are like 45 minutes 55
minute exposure so you actually have a
lot of time so I would run outside
and just lay on the ground under the
southern Milky Way
beautiful right up you know there and I
would just lay there like the snow angel
you know
and it just stare up there and just kind
of let my thoughts sort of pass through
my brain and just like I'm I'm one of it
right we talked about this in the
beginning this is when I personally have
the feeling that I'm a part of it I I
belong here rather than feeling kind of
small yes I'm small but there are many
other small things and lots of small
things make one big hole yeah we're part
of that big hole and um so that's
looking at the inner spirals yes Milky
Way galaxy and just you know this this
dark sky with the with the bright stars
and I have described this in my my book
um years ago
if the Milky Way Is All Bright above you
you don't need a moon or anything you
can walk in the Starlight and you will
find your way there are no trees there
for safety reasons but you wouldn't even
run into a tree right I mean you can see
you can almost see the shadow you know
from from The Starlight because it's
such a dark side and and the stars are
so bright and these are kind of moments
that that kind of change you a little
bit
and if you see the unity of it all yeah
and it's just you and nature and
you know with modern civilization and
all of that we I think we often try a
little bit too hard to be removed from
from nature you know to to be
independent of it and figuring it all
out but at the end of the day we're just
a part of it and and that really helps
me to remember that that you know
well one and the same well that fills me
with hope that because I I tend to think
of us humans as in the very early days
of whatever the heck we are so that
makes me think uh thousands tens of
thousands hundreds of thousands years
from now they will be reaching whatever
we become will be traveling out there to
explore more and more and more no so
we're what you're doing is the early
days of Exploration with the tools we
have yes the early Seafair
at the sky for navigation coming up with
different theories of what uh what's on
the other side that the Earth is
starting to gain an intuition that the
Earth may be round
and then we might be able to navigate
all the way around to get to
um the financial benefits of getting
spices from India whatever the reason
whatever the grant funding process is
all about but ultimately actually
results in a deep understanding of the
mystery that's uh all around us and I
mean it's just to travel out there
I mean to me
the discovery of life in the solar
system
I really hope to see that in my lifetime
some kind of some kind of Life bacteria
something maybe dead because that means
there's life everywhere
and that that just the kind of stuff
that might be out there
all the different
um
all the different environmental
conditions chemically speaking that are
out there and it just seems like when
you look at Earth life finds a way
to survive to thrive in whatever
conditions and so uh
maybe that process just kind of humbles
you as a super exciting to know that
there is life out there of different
forms and of course that raises the
question of um
what is life even we tend to have a very
human-centric perspective
of uh what is a living organism and what
is intelligence and all this kind of
stuff and all the work in artificial
intelligence now is starting to
challenge our ideas of what makes human
beings special
I think we're doing that through all
kinds of ways and I think you're working
some part doing that as well like the
unity you feel is realizing where
uh we're part of this big mechanism of
nature whatever that is that's creating
all kinds of cool stuff from The Humble
pristine Origins to uh to today
um
so what is if you could just kind of
Linger on the on the process of the data
what does the data look like and how
does the data the raw data lead to uh
a discovery of an ancient star
well as a spectroscopist we have to I
guess talk for for a brief moment about
what what a spectrum is yes
um
everyone I hope has seen a rainbow in
the sky that is
that is basically what we're doing uh we
don't send the Starlight through a
raindrop that then gets bounced around
and splits up the light into the rainbow
colors we
um we do it with a spectrograph so
basically a prism so we send a Starlight
through a prism of sorts and that splits
it up and then we record exactly that so
it's a little 2D picture actually of a
spectrum
now uh it's not going to look colorful
it's just black or black and white
different and different colors have of
course different energies that's what
what we record
um more specifically we we record it as
as wavelengths so wavelengths and
frequency and energies all all the same
at the end of the day
um we process that that little image in
the sense that we do a cross cut
and then sum up a few columns so that we
get all the data that we recorded and
what we see is a
um it's a bit funny to describe just
with words but a wiggly line with lots
of dips so the 2D process Spectrum we
call it Continuum so it's just a flat
line basically and then there are dips
so the interesting things are the dips
if you think back of the rainbow what we
actually see in Our Stars is not just a
rainbow but it would be a rainbow with
lots of black lines in it which means
certain little pieces of color have been
eaten Away by a certain amount and so we
can no longer see it as well or not at
all
why is that happening so if we come back
to our Stars what we're observing we're
observing the Stella surface we can
actually never peer without telescopes
inside we only ever go can go after the
surface
and the
surface contains oh the surface layer
contains different kinds of elements
every one of those types of atoms so
elements are just different types of
atoms they absorb different photons that
are coming from the hot core where the
fusion is occurring and so that means
that if you're the Observer you know
with a spectrograph or without
um you will see the Starlight but
certain frequencies certain energies of
that light will have been absorbed by
all the different atoms in the gas
so you see less of them and so those are
the dips and the strength of the dips
tell us you know which element was it
and how much of that element was or is
in in the star
so we have many many dips the the solar
Spectrum for reference you know all the
dips are overlapping because the
abundance of all the elements are so
high it's actually very complicated
Spectrum my Spectra really look like a
straight line and then there's a dip
here and then you have the straight line
again there's a dip there the sun
doesn't have straight lines I mean
that's just all absorbed in some form or
another
um but the old stars have so little of
all the elements that they're only
occasionally these dips that then
indicate okay that one at that
wavelength was iron and here we have
carbon and there's magnesium and sodium
and oh there's a little strontium line
here so we have a much easier way to
um map out this barcode that the
Spectrum you know pretty much is in at
the end of the day and to then measure
the strength of these we call it
absorption lines to then calculate with
existing codes that mimic the physics of
the Stellar hemispheres like how much
was absorbed how many what what kind of
elements were were present in in the
cellar atmosphere
and so this is how we get to our
abundance measurements and then all
together that gives us the the chemical
composition and and that particular
signature in that star
if you uh do you ever look at like the
raw spectrograph and the absorption line
and they're able to see
Intuit some interesting non-standard
outlier kind of patterns
or does this have to do heavy amount of
processing
um we actually process our it's fairly
straightforward to to do our processing
we do it at the telescope so I often
take a shorter exposure first let's say
10 or 15 minutes uh so mostly when I do
Discovery work we would just take a
quick look Spectrum then we process it
while we observe the next uh
then we take a quick look we have what I
call the summary plot it's it's a
collection of little areas in the
spectrum that have the the key positions
uh the positions of the key elements in
it and it's kind of like reading the tea
leaves I have stared at so many Spectra
I just need to know I just need to see
our summary plot and I can tell you
exactly what the numbers are going to be
also and also to tell if it's going to
be promising to look at further exactly
and so that's a thumbs up thumbs down
uh you're worth my time
or not in most cases it's not or it's
good enough we can do a basic analysis
maybe publish this as part of a larger
sample just so you know we output that
we have observed the star and and their
basic nature that that's an important
part to to publish as well
um and uh yeah I had a I had a run so
now we do remote absorbing I do all of
this now from my home from my living
room all night long
um and
um I often work with with colleagues so
we would over zoom and we process the
data we look at it same thing still and
we we just found a star that
um had a very low iron abundance and
then we decided okay that looks
interesting we're just gonna keep
exposing so we took more data on it on
the spot and we're writing up the paper
right now how do you know where to point
the telescope it's not random there's a
lot of work that goes into that
um I began my career by
answering trying to answer that question
as in like doing the search process
that's why I called my my book that I've
written some time ago searching for the
oldest ass because
searching is one thing it's very time
consuming and then on top of that not
everyone finds right and I often don't
find but I keep searching because you
know techniques have established that
yes we can do it if we're just patient
enough and keep going because it's a
numbers game and that's often the case
in science and that's something that not
a not enough is talked about how tedious
it is and how long it takes to get to
that one
Discovery right that that moves the
field further and how difficult it is to
believe that there's a thing to be
discovered yes yes
um if we have the saying I I learned
this I think from my supervisor one star
is a discovery
two is a is a sample and three is a
population so as soon as you found three
of the roughly the same kind you're done
but you need to get there yeah probably
the first is the hardest right yes but
it kind of remains really hard and but
the thing is that at past three many of
us are okay we solved that problem
we've done it three times so we can't do
it that's a thing right that's a
population three iron deficient Stars
let's say right that's one puzzle piece
now we can move on to the next thing
that's an indicator that there's many
more of them yes potentially yes yes yes
so to cut a long story short about the
searching
um we started early on with
um what's called low resolution
spectroscopy of many stars so for
example my thesis work almost 20 years
ago was piggybacking off
um a quasa survey that had collected so
quasars are basically giant supermassive
black holes that are really far away so
you only see a one big bright light
point so it looks like a star but it's
actually just a giant supermassive like
all that outshines it's it's its own
Galaxy
and people had been trying to study
those and they had taken little Spectra
of of you know all things in the sky and
it turns out oh you can fish out the
actual stars from that and and look for
certain signatures
um that might indicate uh Low Middle
City Star so it starts with low
abundances
um and so it was painstaking work to
then take medium resolution spectroscopy
to get a little bit more information and
to use the approximations and to kind of
get candidates that we can then
eventually take to the big class like
Magellan to get a high resolution
Spectrum so we really see the dips of
all the individual elements that then
give us the final answer is it yay
already
um these days uh with another grad
student I just I developed a new
technique to use
um images actually of all the stars in
the sky taken with very narrow filters
so it's like you're wearing very
specific glasses that only let so much
light through and so we can do similar
things
through having several narrow band
filters what we call it to fish out
things that have you know no absorption
over here so just the the straight line
and then a little dip here so a little
something there
and that has proven fairly successful in
recent years so looking at the entire
looking at a broader regions of space
that's right because these stars are a
little bit like the needle in the
haystack right there are not that many
left over and the certainly the galaxy
has made plenty of stars in between we
need to comb through all of those
um to to get to the goods yeah um so we
always start with millions and then work
our way down and in the end we have like
three good candidates I wonder how those
ancient Stars feel that they were
noticed they probably know that nobody
pays attention
I'm just kidding we're all special right
so understands it's good it's inspiring
even if you're the outcast
um in in your pristine nature you still
might nevertheless be noticed I'm hoping
the same about humans if somebody's
observing us
um
is there something else you could say
that's
about the challenges of this kind of
high Precision measurement
uh that you're doing
so this kind of collection of data
looking
trying to come
pull out the signal from the noise out
there
well that's literally what we're doing
in multiple ways actually so we find
trying to find the needle in the
haystack
and then we find something and then it
turns out
it's just a little bit too faint to
actually get the kind of data quality on
it that we would like or that would
would be warranted given the the
potential of the Star right it was like
so there's always noise
there's always a little bit of noise and
you have to try to say like what uh yeah
how special is this when you're looking
at the absorption line yeah how so the
most iron Pro Stars their iron lines are
so tiny that they're literally you know
almost in the noise so you need
incredibly good data to make detections
and and the funny thing is we're looking
for the nothingness of let's say the
iron lines but then we don't want
nothing because if there's nothing in
the Spectrum we can't measure anything
we can only get an upper limit but we'd
really like a measurement so we are
looking for the the last little bit that
you could possibly detect and that's the
strong function of the brightness of the
star because the telescopes have the
size that they do that that's not going
to change for a while hopefully
eventually it will but it's going to be
at least 10 years out
um and so yes we'll often literally
stuck in the noise because we can't make
the measurements so actually the record
holder for the most iron poster only has
an upper limit we can't get enough data
on this to actually pinpoint a
measurement to then take it to our
Theory colleagues and say like give me
this little iron out of your first star
so it's a bit frustrating but also super
exciting at the same time so let's go to
both sides of that Spectrum what's uh
what's like the most exciting Discovery
to you personally where it's is there a
moment you remember that you saw a piece
of data and you kind of your heart
skipped a bit
um yeah yeah of course is it the is it
uh he1327 that was that was definitely
one of those moments I wasn't actually
present at the telescope but we were
send the data immediately for my
colleague
and we just looked at it and our eyes
got really white and it's like oh my God
this is this really what you think it is
so we had to run some numbers and and it
was and it these are magical little
moments yeah the thing is
you know often we we have false
positives yeah and so there's always
this this kind of period and often it's
it's I don't know 10 15 minutes where
you need to make some tests to kind of
make the decision is this really
something I should keep observing now is
this really as good as I think or or am
I being fooled by something right so
actually if you take a spectrum of a
white dwarf a white dwarf is the
leftover core of a star like the sun
that has gone extinct
and why dwarves have lost all their
outer atmosphere so it's just the
hydrogen helium core so they look like a
metal poor style because that's only
hydrogen helium left right but the
hydrogen lines that you can see in the
spectrum of our stars and of the white
dwarfs a little bit wider than normal so
you need to have a good eye just to
check you know does this look a little
bit wider than us is this a white dwarf
who's fooling me here right and so it's
like this moment it's like oh my God
it's just minutes of nervousness yes yes
and sometimes you know it's it's a dad
and sometimes it's not what's been uh
what's been a big that you remember
heartbreak like a painful low point
is it all leading up to the first is it
all about HG 1327 again just the leading
up to it or has there been like a
uh yeah has there been like low points
in this search
um that's a good question
I mean you know it starts with mundane
things as in like you you want your
telescope time you travel there
and the weather is completely cloudy it
rains and you you had three nights which
is a lot and you go home empty-handed
so that's definitely a low point
[Laughter]
uh probably not what you were thinking
of uh but there is a certain
occupational hazard to it which requires
a kind of
resilience and a patience yeah and you
just gotta learn to to live with it um
coming back to reticulum too actually
you know that little dwarf Galaxy that
was a run that we had and the weather
was incredibly bad and I had sent my
student there
um
and I was at home and he calls me at 2AM
and he was like Anna I think I observed
the wrong stuff I'm so sorry
there's this line there this europium
line and it looks like a metal Rich star
and I was like it's cool we all make
mistakes send me the data send me that
summary plot
and so I look at it you know I was like
super tired and it's like
I I can't really tell it doesn't look
wrong but I can't tell you right now
that it's right either so why don't you
go to the next Target
and he calls me back an hour later you
know it looks just the same
what am I supposed to do
and then I joked well maybe we found an
R process Galaxy
let's go to the next one and the weather
was degrading
um and so to cut a long story short
we had to come so he was observing the
right stores it was an r-process Galaxy
the first one we had ever discovered
totally
and I mean unpredicted we had no idea
that this was a thing I mean you know
of course we we thought that you know
such a thing might possibly exist
because why not right Neutron summer
just happened somewhere uh crazy
Supernova probably too but we were not
prepared in that moment to to find this
thing
and
in the end the weather was getting worse
and worse and we wanted to see how many
our processors are in this galaxy so we
managed
by a hairline to observe the nine
brightest stars but the data quality was
atrocious and weather affects the data
quality yes absolutely because these
were really faint Stars
um so we we were really lucky by making
a very tight strategy of getting the
absolute bare minimum for all the stores
so we could at least take a a very crude
look is it a yay or is an a we couldn't
even say yes or no just just to get an
idea because we needed to know
why was that important because
we could only observe this system again
nine months later so there's always a
window of observation yes it was setting
this was our chance and it was going
away with the clouds you know
that was super high stakes but uh we we
we just made it like really it was
almost impossible and it was just the
the thing is this is such a
serendipitous moment in a serendipitous
moment the enhancement of these heavy
elements was so strong that even in this
really crappy data we could still see
the enhancement
right the absorption was so strong
they're stuck out of the noise if the
enhancement wouldn't have been as strong
we would not have been able to say
anything because we wouldn't have been
able to tell
but because it was so extreme it lent us
a hand despite the weather and all to
say like yes this is it
so that was quite the night
look that means a lot of this is just
luck
so that was the first our process Galaxy
discovered yes
people that much that
um do you have hope are you excited
about uh James Webb's Space Telescope
and other telescopes in the future that
uh increase the resolution and the
Precision of what can be detected out
there absolutely
um jwst is fantastic already I am not
planning to use it personally although I
think I'm on one or two observing
proposals actually because similar to
what we already spoke about we're
interested in the same thing we're just
kind of looking at the different sides
of the fence right I have my my old
surviving stars and I concoct these
little stories about what the earliest
galaxies may have looked like what what
the objects were that contributed you
know energy and and elements and all
these things and uh my jwst colleagues
they try to detect some of these
earliest photons from these earliest
systems to look at the energetics and
and other things you know what was there
how many these kinds of things right so
together we're trying to to explore this
first billion years
but we do it in very complementary ways
and so I'm I'm very excited to to see
what what they can come up with and how
that helps me to inform my stories
better and more comprehensively
uh what do you think is the future
of the of the field of Stellar
archeology how much can we
maybe what are the limits of our our
understanding of this first billion
years of our uterus
um well obviously lots of limitations in
the sense that I always say I have a
metal poor star for any of your
questions
because there are so many different
kinds out there
um and we still find new patterns
sometimes right and there needs to be an
explanation the question is is it
ultimately just one quirky star or is it
two or is it three right is it is it a
sample is it a population so we haven't
concluded that kind of work yet so every
metapore Star
is the kind of data point that you can
use to improve the quality of your model
of how the evolution of the early
Universe yes yes and I would say we're
we've made huge progress over the last
20 years when I joined that field it was
in its infancy and there was this
serendipitous discovery of that first
second generation star
and we have filled in the canvas a great
deal since then and this is what I have
greatly enjoyed about doing so because
there was so much Discovery potential
and it's been it's been dying down a
little bit because of all the progress
um it's gonna it's gonna it's on on the
up and coming again because there's so
many large spectroscopic surveys in the
works now that will just provide a
different level of data that we haven't
had before I'm sort of of these older
generation I have only very few
colleagues I work in small teams and I
observe every single star myself
that you know I whatever I can I do
myself I don't generally take other
people's data at least not certainly not
in the end stage and and uh you know I'm
not a big data kind of person although
we're all headed that that way I I
certainly use uh data from the Gaia
astrometric satellite for the kinematics
for example but that's personally a new
thing for me to to use sort of Big Sky
surveys
um that are available
um so it's still very sort of hand grown
field you know where we do our
individual observations
um have enjoyed that a lot but that's
about to change so one star at a time
yes I mean there's power to that to
build up intuition of the early Universe
by looking one star at a time yeah and
and this is how you can really drill
down on the questions that you have
right because you control what data you
get
um otherwise you have the data that you
have right you get what you get and you
don't get upset
I don't like that I'm a little bit
snobby I I really like to formulate my
questions go to the telescope and then
come what may I will try to get it and I
also develop the intuition of where the
data can be relied upon and what it
can't and all the different quirks of
the data and all that kind of stuff yeah
sometimes a lot is lost
in the aggregation of the noisy data
yeah yeah yeah and and that's always the
danger if you have someone else's data
that you just don't really understand
the you know the limitations and
completeness things how certain things
were set up and you know you get out
what you put in so I'm I'm really
particular about that and it certainly
paid off for me that's one of the main
Notions that I try to teach in my
classes and to my my students that
you need to be able to formulate your
quest question really well because
otherwise you're going to get an answer
to a different question but you won't
notice that it had that the goal post
has shifted in the meantime right so
your interpretation can only be as good
as the question if you need to change
your question that's cool do it
but then you know it needs to pair up
with your interpretation again and so
knowing really being in the know about
every step of what happens that relates
to Quality results I think that's why I
have sometimes a little trouble with
with sort of big data and statistical
analysis yes on average that's true I'm
not debating that but I I'm the kind of
person I like to look at the outlier so
not the bulk but you know the special
ones and they just need to be treated in
a different way and there needs to be an
acknowledgment of that different ways
for different things so uh big data can
look at uh divorce rates
and uh perhaps you and I are more
interested in the individual love
stories yes
um so
I don't know if it's possible to say but
what do you think is the big discoveries
that are waiting
uh is it on the different dynamics of
the yield
the common narrative the common story of
how some of these metal poor stars are
formed
is it where are the discoveries in this
field that you think will come
I think the individual discoveries are
actually
we've made most of those certainly
through individual Stars
um finding yet another second generation
size incredibly important for me but
isn't isn't really going to move the
needle
finding 50 of them or 100 of them that
would move the needle but that's in
order or two magnitudes up
and new search techniques and new uh
surveys may enable that but would you
still call that a discovery
right so that's just a scale that's a
scale yes so I think about it more like
literally of the puzzle let's say you
have a thousand piece puzzle and you
know you have 900 pieces in there
if you're a person like me I want to get
to the last ones I'm not gonna leave it
it's like okay I see broadly what this
is going to look like right I'm done now
no I want to get to the last one
so is the picture globally going to
change no
are we going to figure out all the
details and how it really works yes
right so really careful getting detailed
mapping into it the the ancient uh the
ancient stars of our universe yeah
because I think that's what many of us
scientists are a real little bit
detailed obsessed but I think that's
that's our job too right to really kind
of make it airtight to really walk away
saying I fully understand this not just
broadly
but you know I really know we really
know now and so more and more of that is
going to happen
um and so I think this is probably true
across astronomy these individual
10 Sigma discoveries become less and
less
if they were easy we would have made
them already right which means we have
made many of them but really filling in
the details is is is is is the next sort
of level of Discovery maybe we need to
find a new word for that
um
the hopes and expectations that go along
with the word Discovery are so enormous
we we may not always be able to live up
to that but it doesn't mean that we're
not finding out new things it's just a
different kind of quality because the
questions have shifted you close one
door sending that 10 new open doors that
that we want to explore and March
through and that's the you know finding
these last puzzle pieces here and there
that Miri make it airtight so there's a
lot of value a lot of power and Beauty
to the discovery
in the big picture of our universe and
in the details yeah we need both
absolutely